[موسيقى]
قباله السواحل الاوكرانيه تستعرض موسكو
قدراتها العسكريه تدريبات بالذخيره الحيه
على سيناريو اعتراض سفن في عرض البحر
والمناورات الميدانيه ليست سوى انعكاس
لارتفاع نبره التهديدات المتبادله بين
موسكو
فمن بوابه اتفاق الحبوب الذي انهار
بانسحاب روسيا منه يعود البحر الاسود الى
دائره الاهتمام منذرا بتصعيد محتمل
اوكرانيا تحذر من انها ستواصل اعتبار جميع
السفن المتجهه الى الموانئ الروسيه اهدافا
عسكريه في رد على تحذير روسي مماثل لترد
موسكو مره اخرى باتهام كييف بالضلوع في
هجمات ارهابيه تهدد الملاحه في البحر
الاسود في اشاره لاستهداف ميناء سباستوبل
مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي ومواقع شبه
جزيره القرم بما فيها جسر القرمستراتيجي
وهي مناطق تحت السيطره الروسيه هجمات رد
عليها الجيش الروسي حسب ما اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع بقصف مكثف ومستمر لمدن ساحليه
اوكرانيه اهمها
هجمات ذهب مسؤولون روس اثرها الى حد
المطالبه بضم مزيد من المناطق الاوكرانيه
لروسيا لحرمان كييف من اي منفذ على البحر
الاسود
ولمنافذ البحر الاسود اهميه للطرفين كيف
تؤكد انها ستستعيد السيطره على المناطق
التي اقتطعتها روسيا كليا او جزئيا بينما
تتمسك موسكو بالابقاء عليها منفذا للمياه
الدافئه
ومعركه البحر الاسود معركه مؤجله منذ
بدايه الحرب ففي اليوم الاول للحرب على
اوكرانيا بسطت روسيا سيطرتها على جزيره
الافعى ذات الرمزيه الجزيره تقع شمال غرب
البحر الاسود وتبعد قرابه 35 كيلومترا عن
الشواطئ الاوكرانيه لتضطر الى الانسحاب
منها بعد عده اشهر في معركه خسرت لاحقا
فيها دره اسطودها البحري موسكوفا الملقبه
صائد حاملات الطائرات